thing is just about assigning yourself
the right story I didn't want to go to
college though my dad wanted me to go to
college why did you come back to him oh
I came back I had about $175,000 and I
thought that's all I would need to live
the rest of my life have you ever run
into that guy again no he needs
protection now when you had your first
annual meeting how many people showed up
at that well we had 12 but you had to
count my aunt Katie and my Uncle Fred
any word of advice you give to somebody
who's a young investor who would like to
emulate you would you fix your time
please well people wouldn't recognize me
at my Tyler's fix book okay just leave
it this way all right
I don't consider myself a journalist and
nobody else would consider myself a
journalist I began to take on the life
of being an interviewer even though I
have a day job running a private equity
firm how do you define leadership what
is it that makes somebody tick
[Music]
preciate it for the night from capital
all right well just Frank yeah all right
we're at your favorite restaurant in
Omaha
all right so why do you like it so much
is it the food or the price or the
combination of both it's the food and
the price and the Heritage I four
generations of the garage family were
involved or Palika rot and I went to
grammar school together and so I've
known the people over the years the
stakes are great you know the prices are
right so had lunch here earlier today
was very good it wasn't that expensive
and I quite enjoyed it a lot cheaper
than New York and walked a lot that's
why I buy I buy people lunch here and
then they could buy me the lunch in New
York that's a good deal good arbitrage
you grew up in Omaha but then you moved
to Washington when your father became a
congressman right how did you start your
business career in Washington with
various pinball machines or golf
businesses yeah I was like to have a
couple of businesses going in and the
best business we had was the pinball
machine business which was the Wilson
coin-operated machine company and that
was named after the high school my
partner and I went to but but we had we
had our machines and barber shops and
the barbers always want to put us in
machines with flippers which were just
coming in but those machines cost 350
bucks whereas an old obsolete machine
cost 25 bucks so we always told them we
take it up with mr. Wilson this mythical
mr. Wilson he was one tough guy I got to
tell you so when you graduated from high
school you weren't as interested in
academics I assumed at that time I was
not interested and your high school
yearbook said he's likely to be a
stockbroker but he's very good in math
why did you go to Wharton and why did
you only stay two years there I didn't
want to go to college and my dad want me
to go to college and we didn't have SATs
then but he practically would have done
the SATs for me so he in the truth I and
I always want to please my dad I mean he
was the hero to me and still is but so
he kept kind of enjoying me along and
said well why don't we just fill out an
application for the hell of it and so he
suggested Wharton and I applied there
and they let me in and after the first
year I wanted to quit and go into
business and my dad said well give it
one more year and so I went the second
year
and I said I still want to quit and he
said well you know you've got almost
enough credits if you go to Nebraska
which I was quite willing to do for one
year you can get out in three years so
that's what I did
has warden ever called you up and said
well you were a half graduate you should
give us some money or they never bother
you so far they haven't tried that line
but they may after they watch this so
after that you wanted to go to business
school
yeah I'd won some minor scholarship but
the Nebraska to go to any graduate
school I wanted to that they'd give me
500 bucks and so I applied my dad
suggested Harvard so I applied and you
didn't get in I didn't get it I mean no
it took 10 minutes for the guy near
Chicago interviewed me so I spent about
ten hours going to see him and he looked
at me and he said forget it
have you ever run into that guy again or
heard from him since now he needs
protection now so I guess Harvard that
doesn't come after you for money because
they turn you down but you went to
Columbia Business School and why did you
go to Columbia well I was at the
University of Omaha what was then called
the University of Omaha library in
August and I was leafing through
catalogs and I just happen to see that
Columbia had Graham and Dodd as teachers
and I I read their book but I had no
idea that they were teaching so I wrote
Dean Dodd and I said the dear Dean Dodd
I said I thought you guys were dead I
said but not your life I'd really like
to come to the club if you can get me in
so you did assume pretty well at
Columbia Business School I did okay
there yeah he worked for mr. Graham and
his partnership and how did that work
well it was terrific in the sense I was
working for my hero but then was going
to retire in a couple of years and so I
was only back there about a year and a
half but but every day I was excited
about being able to work for him so what
you were good at was picking stocks
according to his formula which was to
look for companies that were undervalued
now we call it value investing did you
realize that he had some principles that
were very unique and is that why you
followed his guidance well by the time I
went to work for him I probably could
have recited the words of his book
better than he could I read his books
multiple times and so it was more a
question of being inspired by him
was by learning something new from him
why did you come back to Oman III I
wanted to come back to Omaha I I had
made many friends in New York a lot of
friends in New York but we had two kids
by that time and I lived in White Plains
I take the train and they take the train
back and it didn't strike me as much of
the life compared to to being here in
Omaha and and both sets of grandparents
were alive at that time and it just and
uncles and aunts and I always a more
pleasant place to live
right so you buy a house here I rent a
house you rented a house at $475 a month
okay and when did you buy your house
that you're still in in 1958 my third
third child was on the way so you start
a partnership here and how did you raise
money well they've been actually when I
came back I had about $175,000 and I
thought that's all I would need to live
the rest of my life I could take care of
everything so I really planned to go to
school I thought about going to law
school
just think how successful you could have
been as a lawyer that's true I've
regretted it ever since
I know so in your first partnership when
you had people cobble together some
money how much money did you actually
cobble together well we met one night in
May early in May of 1956 and there were
seven people there aside from myself and
they put in a hundred and five thousand
dollars and I put in a hundred dollars
so we started with hundred and five
thousand one hundred dollars and I gave
them a little piece of paper called the
ground rules
but then ultimate you ended that
partnership I thought well what happened
was that between May of 56 and January
1st to 62 I started ten more
partnerships I made a mistake
I had no secretary no accountant or
anything so every time I buy a stock I'd
break it into 11 tickets I'd write 11
checks
I kept 11 sets of books filed eleven tax
returns and and and I did it all myself
and I took the liberty of all the stocks
because I was worried it was other
people's money so I could I'm the bank
and have these things delivered draft it
finally I got wise and on January 1st 62
I put all 11 of the previous
partnerships together and something
called Buffett partnership I ran that
till the end of 1969 at which time I
dissolved it dissolve that one but then
in 1969 you started a new partnership no
in 1969 I mailed by that time we had
about 100
five million dollars in the partnership
and about 70 million or so that was in
cash to be distributed and the balance
was in three stocks mostly Berkshire
Hathaway that I distributed pro rata to
everybody okay and then you started
buying more stocks through the vehicle
Berkshire Hathaway and stocks and and
business was yelling what would you say
is the reason for your ability to do
this is that you studied the companies
more than anybody else you stuck to your
principles you're smarter than other
people people were just caught up with
fads you didn't get caught up with fads
what would you say is the reason for
this success well the first ruler to
quite an extent we we bought businesses
that we thought were decent businesses
at sensible prices and we had good
people to run them but we also bought
marketable securities in Berkshire over
time the emphasis shifted from
marketable securities over to buying
businesses what was the theory behind
buying a railroad because people thought
they were kind of fossils as businesses
the railroad business had a bad century
they're kind of like they should all
gonna come everybody has a bad century
now that the David
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over the years you've bought a number of
companies and had steaks and companies
one of the ones that I know very well is
Washington Post how did that come about
well in 1973 the Washington Post
coming up on public in 1971 write about
the Pentagon Papers type time but in 73
the Nixon administration was through
bebe rebozo was appalling Nixon's they
were challenging the licenses of two of
the Florida television stations the post
owned so the stock went from 37 down to
16 now it's 16 there were about 5
million shares outstanding so the whole
Washington Post Company was something
for 80 million dollars and that included
the newspaper for big TV stations
Newsweek you know and some other assets
and no death to speak up so the
Washington Post Company which was
intrinsically worth four or five hundred
million dollars was selling for about 80
million in the market
we've bought most of our socket about
the equivalent of 100 million in the
market and and it was it was ridiculous
I mean you had a business that
unquestionably was worth four or five
times what was selling for and Nixon
wasn't going to put them out of business
when you're doing these analyses then
and now do you have computers that help
you or how did you actually read all
when you just get printing materials or
how did you in those days get the
materials to read about the Washington
Post and how do you do it today well
same pretty much the same way except
there's fewer opportunities now but I
met Bob Woodward back and and and he'd
just come out with all the Presidents
ban and all of a sudden is that all 30
years of Ag was getting quite wealthy
and we had we had breakfast or lunch
over at the Madison Hotel he said what
do I do with this money and I said I
said investing is just about assigning
yourself the right story I said imagine
Ben Bradlee this morning said to you
what is the washington post company
worth what would you do if you have to
write the story in a month you go out
and interview TV brokers and newspaper
brokers and the owners and it's a crime
value each asset i said that's what i do
i assign myself the right story and it's
nothing more than that now there's some
stories i can't write if you ask me to
write a story on you know what is some
glamorous but non profit making business
worth i don't know how to write that
story but if you ask me to write a story
on what is
Potomac Electric Power words or
something like that I can write the
story and that's what I'm doing every
day I'm assigning myself a story and
then I go out and so you get the annual
reports and then you read them just like
other people might read novels you read
annual reports right and then do you do
the calculations of what things are
worth in your head or don't have
computers that help you know if you need
you need to carry something out to four
decimal places forget it today do you
use a computer today even I use it's my
bridge and I use it I use it to go to
search to search a lot yeah so here's a
computer in your office use I don't use
them I don't have one in the office but
I have one at home and like for a
smartphone if somebody wants to you know
get a hold of you can they get a hold of
you on a smart phone or a mobile
telephone I know a smart phone is too
smart for me and a computer you use
rarely well I use it quite as one of the
trick questions that Bill Gates and I
get one we're talking odds is who's on
the computer more excluding email and
the answer is I probably am because I
probably play 12 hours a week a bridge
on it and then I use it a lot for for
search but who do you play bridge with
is it anonymous people on bridge right
now my name is t-bone and I play with a
woman in San Francisco goes by the name
of Searle and she's a two-time world
champ and I'm new time world chump so
we're we're good we've been playing
together for decades and are you at the
world-class level after all these girls
know that I I she you couldn't have a
better teacher than she is but the
student had limitations
now you mentioned Bill Gates how did you
actually come to know Bill Gates it came
about because the Meg Greenfield who was
the editor of the editorial page of the
post called me in the late 1980s and she
said Warren I've always loved the
Pacific Northwest she'd grown up there
and she said I want to know whether I
have enough money to be able to afford
to buy a house a kind of a vacation type
house I'm Bainbridge Island near Seattle
and I said Meg anybody that calls and
asked me whether they got enough money
does have enough money so I go call that
don't have it so she bought the house so
she invited me in Kate Graham a few
people up to the house and she knew the
elder cases so she called Mary gates and
then Mary went to work
bill to try and get him to come and bill
so I'm not gonna go down there to be
some stockbroker something yeah and Mary
wasn't very firm type and said you're
coming and he said I'm not coming by
they started negotiating hours and she
said four hours and he said one hour and
this went back and forth and he came
down and when we met we talked for about
11 hours straight without Peter yeah so
that was the beginning of relationship
yeah we hit it off but you never bought
any his shares or you just never I
bought a hundred shares just to keep
track of what this young kid was doing
okay and he's now on your board is that
right that's correct
so the relationship has become very
close and you get involved with him in
many philanthropic things as well oh
yeah yeah we we have a lot of fun
talking so let me just ask about the
philanthropic things that you've done
with Bill and with Melinda kind of that
idea of giving away your money to
somebody else's foundation come to you
well I originally had planned that that
my first wife would handle the
disposition of all everything that we we
had we and we came that conclusion 120s
and we started something called the
Buffett foundation over 50 years ago but
in but it didn't give a lot way a lot of
money during those intermediate years
because I felt I was a compounding at a
rate that I could give away billions a
set of millions if I waited a little
while
she died in 2004 so that that plan
disappeared and then I was faced with
the question of how do I give away this
money in a way that that goes to the
people I want without me doing all the
work so you called bill or Melinda one
day and said guess what I'm going to
give you the bulk of my fortune what was
their reaction wasn't quite as elegant
as that actually I you know I've been
asked that I don't remember that clearly
but I just some point I didn't call them
up it was done over the phone I think
good night and you didn't ask them say
well called the Bill and Melinda Gates
and Warren Buffett foundation you don't
know what your name no I did not think
that would do any good so you are on the
board of the Bill Melinda Gates
Foundation now that is true but they run
it I'm gonna give them stock
what would you say are the some of the
highlights the deals that you're most
proud of you know let's take one that
you did recently the biggest deal you've
ever done was Precision Castparts about
37 billion dollars per day yeah it was
it was between 32 and 33 billion of cash
and then we assumed about 4 billion at
that okay so how much you spend 37
billion you spent a year studying the
company no how much time did you spend
with the CEO I met the CEO I think on
July 1st of last last year and he
happened to be calling on certain
shareholders and one of the fellows in
our office had had a position at the
stock for some times so it was an
accident I met him if I'd been out
playing golf or something I never would
have happened but I went in and I liked
him I heard and talked for 30 minutes
and I then said to the fellow in our
office I said call him tomorrow and and
say if he would like to receive a cash
bid from Berkshire Hathaway we would
supply one and if he wouldn't like to
receive one you know forget we ever
called that was it you do hire any
investment bankers health analysis no do
you ever hire investment bankers to help
you analyze a company not to help
analyze economy sometimes sometimes we
they're involved in the deal and we're
perfectly willing to pay off that
commission one time you told me a story
about how an investment banker was hired
by somebody you were going to try to buy
what happened on that was I said we'd
pay $35 a share for a company then in
American energy and and they hired an
investment banker and the investment
guru came out and spent about a week and
they they they kept if they want to send
a big bill at the end and they said well
you've got to increase your price to
make us look good I said I'm not really
worried about whether you look good so
they hung around all mall for about a
week and finally they call up and sort
of pleaded and said you know can't you
increase your price somewhat so that we
can send a bill and get paid
appropriately for our non services and
so I said okay you can tell them we'll
pay thirty five dollars and five cents
and you can say you got the last nickel
out of me so that's what we paid 35 or
five knew normally you make a price and
you don't party and you ever do any
unfriendly deals no no no I even say
Berkshire Hathaway originally was an
unfriendly deal but no we're just not
interested
not that unfriendly deals aren't
necessarily bad
they're management's that should be
replaced but now people must call you
every day and say I have a deal for you
it's perfect and how often any of these
deals ever pan out
they don't call every day and we've made
our Arkwright criteria fairly clear so
there's relatively few that call and
when somebody calls I can usually tell
within two or three minutes whether it
deals likely to happen or not there's
just a half a dozen fillers and it
either makes it through the filters or
it doesn't one time I was told that you
got a letter from somebody from Israel
correct saying I'd like you to look at
look at my company now what's the
likelihood as somebody from Israel sends
a company prospectus to you over the
transom and you say you're going to buy
it and you did buy it yeah we did buy it
we gave we bought eighty percent of it
at that time for four billion and then
we later bought the remaining 20% but
before you bought it did you go to
Israel to look at the company no I did
not go to Israel
I hope it's there and you were happy
with what you bought absolutely and you
also bought one of the biggest railroads
in the world that's correct and that's
worked out okay we just forgot okay what
was the theory behind buying a railroad
because people thought they were kind of
fossils as businesses the railroad
business had a bad century they're kind
of like the Chicago company everybody
has a bad century now that but finally
the the railroad industry got
rationalized quite an extent and
modernized and and the railroad business
is a good business it's not it's not a
great business but it's a good business
and in the fall of 2009 we already owned
a fair amount of BNSF permit in Northern
Santa Fe and the price it looked like we
could do it at a sensible price so that
was a Thursday and on Friday I said we
would pay $100 per share if the
directors were interested then he
checked with the directors over the
weekend and the following Sunday we had
a contract sign somebody from the White
House called and said would you mind
having a tax named after you and I said
no if all the diseases have been taking
my question I I'll take a taxi
David Rubenstein show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your view still is the best place in the
world to invest to the United States
well certainly it has to be the best of
it it's the best I know and so it it's
been wonderful I mean nobody has sold
America short since 1776 and and and
enjoyed that the what happened
subsequently but we were having roughly
2% or less slower growth in the last
couple years you think that it's
possible to ever grow three and four and
five percent again in this economy there
will be some years but 2% growth if you
have a little less than 1% population
growth means in one generation 25 years
call it that we will add maybe 18 or 19
thousand dollars of GDP per capita
family of four seventy five thousand
sigh so we're just beginning that one
percent you know my my life has been a
product of compound interest it may be
better to do it at higher rates but if
you have an already prosperous economy
and we've got the most prosperous
economy the world's ever seen and you
keep compounding it over time people
will be living far better twenty years
from now than they are now you have said
your secretary pays a higher tax rate
than you do in counting counting
counting payroll taxes yes right and so
your favor of changing that some years
ago somebody from the White House not
the president called and said that
they've read my views on taxation and
they said would you mind having a tax
named after you and I said well if all
the diseases have been taken away why
shouldn't I'll take a tax so and so
they've referred to this but I really do
feel that anybody that's making millions
of dollars a years should have a
combined payroll and income tax that
that is at least 30 percent and in my
office everybody in the office does have
that except me how do you think you
became a Democrat when your father was a
big Republican and you're living a very
conservative state how do you think that
evolved civil rights more than anything
else I mean I I didn't think about it
when I was you know twelve years old or
fourteen years old and I went to Atlas
steel and it was a school for blacks
just a few hundred yards away and
it just never dawned on me how different
life was for for other people and then
as I got to see more of the world I just
decided that there were a lot of things
that were unfair and the Democrats seem
to be doing a little bit more about it
in berkshire hathaway today you have an
annual meeting that attracts roughly
40,000 people when you had your first
annual meeting how many people showed up
at that well we had 12 but but you had
to count my aunt Katie and my Uncle Fred
and a couple of managers wait we usually
had about two outsiders and when you
start at Berkshire Hathaway did you ever
in your wildest imagination think that
you could build a company that became
one of the biggest in the world was that
ever in your plan sir no no I I just
I've always just kind of put one foot in
front of the other what is it that you
would like to have as your legacy as you
think I'd like to be the oldest man that
ever lived actually but no I I like
teaching and so if if I've been a decent
teacher and I have a lot of university
students come out every year and today
is there anything on your bucket list
that you would like to do that you
haven't done I'd have done it you know
if there's anything I wanted to do I go
dad money has no utility time as utility
to me but but money in terms of going
making trips are doing only more houses
or having a boat or something it has no
utility to me what so it has a lot of
you suddenly other people which is the
reason for the Giving Pledge what
motivates you to still run a company
when most people your age are playing
shuffleboard or they're relaxing or
doing something
yeah they spend all week planning their
haircut usually I I get to do everyday
what I love with people that I love I
mean it doesn't get any better than that
and so the greatest pleasure in your
life other than doing interviews like
this is is what looking at new companies
making investments giving away the money
what deed gives you the most pleasure
your grandchildren all is all of the
above I mean but the truth is that that
I regard Berkshire Hathaway sort of like
somebody that a painter regards a
painting the difference being that the
campus is unlimited so there's no finish
line at Berkshire and it's it's a game
that you can continue to play any word
of advice you give to somebody who's a
young investor who would like to emulate
you what you would recommend that they
do to kind of build something close to
what you've done
think you should look for the job that
you would want to hold if you didn't
need a job I mean you're you're probably
only going to live once Shirley MacLaine
may differ without our few people but
and you don't want to go sleepwalking
through life and you really whether you
make X or 120 percent of X really isn't
remotely as important as to whether in
most cases you marry the right person
and you also find something that you
would do if you didn't need the money
and I've had that job for you know 50 or
more years and I was lucky and then I
sort of found early on what turned me on
that way but but don't settle for
something if you can possibly don't
worry about making the most money this
week or next month I mean when I went
there I offered to work for Ben Graham I
said I'll work for nothing and I met it
you know I mean I just the idea being
turned on so look look look for the job
that turned on find a passion the David
Rubin stuns
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm mark halperin and I'm John Heilemann
with all due respect to Team Trump it
looks like the Democrats think they've
got this one in the bag on a day when
the New York Times delivers thrilling
details about a new Tribe Called Quest
album boo boo we strike a musical theme
on the show tonight including Donald
Trump's change of tune and the Clinton
campaigns blue state jam session but
first the polls pick up tempo we can
barely keep up with the onslaught of
surveys from key state polls by
Quinnipiac CNN and other organizations
that flooded our inboxes today with less
than a week before Eid a Florida remains
a razor-thin race in one poll Clinton is
up by one point among likely voters and
the other she is up by two points in
Ohio Donald Trump is ahead by five
percentage points in North Carolina
Clinton leads by three and in
Pennsylvania Clinton leads by five
points in one poll and four in another
in Wisconsin where Donald Trump campaign
yesterday and Mark Halperin was Clinton
is still up by six
while her advantage in Colorado has
shrunk to three points while in Virginia
she's up by five percentage